okay so here we are this is eating your
feed eating eat eating this is eating
your feed my name is Nikki my best
friend is Andrew no it's not it's Adam
and today he's challenging me to make a
chocolate crepe cake I am a big fan of
crepes so not to toot my own horn I'm
pretty good at making crepes
I've never made a crepe cake but a crepe
cake has a lot of crepes you essentially
just start piling them on top of each
other with some whipped cream in between
and then you kind of clean up the edges
you top it with like a chocolate ganache
I'm gonna finish it off I think I can do
this in case I can't do this my friend
RIA is here
tasty producer chef extraordinaire you
and I have actually gone to eat crepe
cakes together
I don't remember okay we went to brunch
whatever I was there I haven't made
chocolate crepes so I'm gonna sub out
some flour for some cocoa powder yeah
making the batter take one okay um I
have my things
I'm usually a big fan of whole milk
because I love fat
but for crepes you want to get skim what
was I saying I'm using a recipe that I
have used in the past it's from world of
crepes calm so first thing I'm gonna do
is melt some butter
I wonder who invented putting the
tablespoons on the stick of butter
wrapping because I bet you before that
was a real pain in the ass I hope you're
ready 1 cup flour 1/2 a cup cocoa powder
you don't want to have a full amount of
flour and add cocoa butter because
that's too many dry ingredients there
those 3 tablespoons sugar and a pinch of
salt yeah 200 1/2 cups of milk what's
the date today history if it's bad I
will smell it
ok so we're one day past on this milk oh
wow you're drinking it all right well 4
eggs oh yeah we're mixing the eggs and
the milk together
and then we're gonna slowly incorporate
it into our dry ingredients all right
here we go I'm not trying to be fancy I
have a broken pinky and I can't get eggs
juice on it feels good get it all
incorporated at this point it's kind of
important to like assess if it's wet
enough like if your batter is too thick
right now you can just add a little bit
more milk I'm gonna let this sit for
about 30 minutes to an hour I don't know
why it has something to do with gluten
but it's a thing you should do because
it's good for the batter and then just
before I use it I'm gonna strain all of
it well rested batter I'm there strain
enough No
nice and smooth yay so flipping crepes
can be difficult because they're so thin
I'm gonna use this to like lift up the
edges and then I pretty much just use my
fingers to just flip it because it's the
easiest thing I'm gonna butter the pan
so the batter doesn't stick so the thing
with crepes is you want them thin so you
put in a little bit of batter and then
you kind of gotta like maneuver it so it
covers the whole bottom of the pan so
it's like a nice thin layer
yeah that's not hot enough that's not
enough insects cooking faster than that
the batter is okay this is not my usual
experience it's too wet
I'm pretty good at making crepes I have
made crepes a bunch of times before this
never happens to me in effect did
something wrong no I need to flip it oh
this is difficult I'm gonna try again
[Music]
this is messy but it definitely looks
better already
okay so I just one more hot enough it
might be the cocoa powder I no longer
feel great about this come on see
definitely made improvements darling
super delicious
[Music]
a little all right I gotta do this
faster Oh mother
Roger gotta work on my flip out team
mama
[Music]
I wonder if my batter is to fit okay I'm
gonna try thinning out the batter and I
got no milk this is not one day expired
know anything really hot now - I only
did it in the video
can we call rate few things these are my
first few I send out the butter with
some milk I'm having a really hard time
flipping I feel like first you know two
or three crepes yeah I also used a wider
spatula and I flip see ya
oh I didn't you didn't you just went
straight in yeah should I do that for
hate me I've made crepes before Rhea do
you have a picture I can call my wife
she can tell you hi
hey what's up I'm just gonna ask you a
question you just have to answer
honestly okay okay am I good at making
crepes are you good at making crepe
yeah crepes yeah
you're so good at making cranky they
taste just like they did when we were in
Paris believe in you thank you maybe the
bottle pleeeease feeling also
something's wrong
I probably failed in making the batter I
think more flour
westcoast less cocoa powder yeah let's
ease my recipe choo-choo-choo or should
we do four cups on the left you have to
like over
I'm just doing your recipe has a so that
you combine all the dry ingredients then
eggs looks like chocolate pizza dough
and then melted butter 1/2 cup old mail
cut the time I want to use wire whisk it
start here so it makes well especially
something like this like really thick
okay what if this doesn't work but how
lumpy this is chunky why we strange okay
one string isn't so chunky I think it
wasn't unlike what so much dollar look I
know I mixed it
let's make selamat argh I think it's
less chunky now yeah better yeah cover
it up 30 minutes let's see if this works
oh dear then this looks thick
[Music]
I didn't mean to do that I'm keeping
that I'm gonna show that to Rea okay
test one I laid it on pretty thick gray
so that was okay since we're making a
cake 19 to go hey I think I can handle
making more than one at a time and I
think Maria will be really impressed
with me
hot second cup top oh they all look
roughly the same size cooking crepes two
at a time
Oh huh third cooktop I think I can do it
three crepes three creeps at a time all
right
you're there you did it cake assembly
now that I have I think I guess I never
counted them
one
so we have 26 creams I'm gonna start by
whipping cream we want stiff peaks but
we don't want butter I think that's good
right every morning I got an ice cream
scoop so that I'm measuring how much
cream I'm putting on top of each one so
it's as even as possible good about that
hey tip number two is gonna take forever
so remember the edges this is gonna take
a long time I thought the hard part was
over and then like 20-something more to
go yeah I think it's already domain II -
Adam yeah those like fancy bakeries who
do they have do this someone makes you a
crepe cake don't take it for granted
it took them all day
I'm out of cream so this one is the last
one on top very nice that's it I am
twenty
I'm gonna put this in the fridge while I
make my ganache so that the cream can
cool and it'll be more firm when I pour
hot chocolate all over it
but uh now I'm gonna make the ganache
but I need Ria's help cuz apparently
she's a secret tip for me oh look it's
my friends hi friends ganache heat up
two things a cream cream or cream
ganache cream watch
20:18 have you cut yourself cutting
chocolate before
[Music]
for adding some sugar to the cream for
the ganache but not too much since
there's sugar in the cream so pour it
until it covers it count to 30
[Music]
thirty okay 30 seconds time to mix
off the milk hey clean out the edges I
do that like guides and just cut wow
this is I could just ruin it all
yeah oh that's such a thick layer oh
[Music]
yeah look at that cover the edges this
is gonna be so toddler wow that's too
thick layers of chalk
Andrews clapping only Andrew ever claps
for me look at these layers I think
they're pretty good nice and even not
too donned twenty crepes Oh
don't look at those look at that it
looks like the princess and the pea know
something about all the layers reminds
me of all those manners where's the beef
[Music]
anyways my finger tips are pretty much
burn this was worth it I got 20 crepes
it's pretty even it's not doing too much
the ganache is nice and shiny these
layers are so satisfying it's really
tasty it will probably take you most of
your day and make it feel like to
Lincoln but I'd like with this out for
like a birthday party brunch if you make
this footbridge I will remember you
experience today I do make it again yeah
oh yes
[Music]